Using alpha min, I get a value of 57,400 kilometers.
I've done a little bit of rounding.
And using alpha max, I get a value of 38,700 kilometers.
Remember the true value of the circumference is about 40,000 kilometers,
which is between these 2 numbers.
So actually, using this angular error, we can actually explain away
why Eratosthenes made the mistake that he did--
maybe.
In reality, Syene is only about half a degree north of what's called the Tropic of Cancer.
And the Tropic of Cancer is the location where the sun's rays truly are vertical
during the summer solstice.
Being half a degree off actually wouldn't be enough to account for Eratosthenes's error,
so we should keep doing our calculation.
Anyways, this was an estimate based on this toy model of a well.
And since I can't go back in time and look down the same well that Eratosthenes did,
I have no idea of knowing if this estimate is correct.